[Applaudissements]
si jamais tous les
le premier regard tout ce qu'on s'est
dit dans le fond du bar si jamais lavés
n'est pas mon côté
ne veut pas de nous la joue
maudit
on se perd à ses yeux méchament
on se retrouve je suis sûre comme un jeu
d'enfant on se plaît
à coup sûr mais avec le grand comme
rassure comme dans nos jeux d'antan je
suis tentée
[Musique]
j'ai mal
tu as gagné je suis grand
un os
mais je suis tombé
je suis dans mes
huit ans m
ce que j'ai
à
[Musique]
jamais ta peau et confiance en moi je
comprends ta douleur tu verras ça ira si
jamais du doubs j'te fais la promesse
soeur de garder sur la route et qu'on
l'attendait
on se plaît
ah c'est sûr
longtemps on se retrouvera je suis sûr
comme un jeu d'enfant on se perdra pour
sûr mais avec le temps comme rassure
canton
jeux d'antan je suis tombé
[Musique]
le ciel
go
je suis
[Musique]
non
80 m
je suis touché bravo va gagner je suis
pour
enfermé combelles
suivent en l'air
tous
[Musique]
puis le ciel
je lui tendais
[Musique]
vous
[Applaudissements]